♪ ♪
ALONG >> Tucker: HERE IS
SOMETHING THAT IS KIND OF SAD BT
TRUE.
THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
PEOPLE MAY DISLIKE SOMETHING BUT
IN REAL LIFE, NOTHING REALLY
CHANGES UNTIL POWERFUL PEOPLE
STAND UP AGAINST IT.
THAT IS WHY THIS IS A
SIGNIFICANT STORY.
COUNTRY MUSIC STAR TRAVIS TRITT
HAS ANNOUNCED HE IS CANCELING
ANY PERFORMANCE IN ANY VENUE
THAT MANDATES MASKS, REQUIRES
COVID VACCINATIONS, OR PUSHES
UNREASONABLE COVID CASTING
PROTOCOLS.
WHY IS HE DOING THAT?
TRAVIS TRITT JOINS US TO
EXPLAIN.
TRAVIS TRITT, WE ARE HONORED TO
HAVE YOU ON THE SHOW, THANKS FOR
COMING ON, AND GOING TO ASK YOU
TO EXPEND WHY YOU'RE DOING THIS
AND LET YOU TALK.
>> WELL, WE HAVE DONE ABOUT 75
SHOWS SO FAR THIS YEAR.
ALL OVER THE COUNTRY, TUCKER.
AND IN SPITE OF THE FACT THAT
SOME PEOPLE WOULD TRY TO LABEL
THESE AS BEING
"SUPER-SPREADERS," THE ACTUAL
NUMBERS DON'T REFLECT THAT AT
ALL.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, QUITE THE
OPPOSITE.
WHEN MOST OF THESE AREAS, WE
HAVE SEEN THE COVID NUMBERS
ACTUALLY DROP DRAMATICALLY OVER
THE LAST FEW WEEKS AND MONTHS,
AND SO IT CAME AS QUITE A SHOCK
TO ME AND A LOT OF MY FANS WHEN
AFTER THE FIRST WEEK OF OCTOBER,
DURING THE FIRST WEEK
OF OCTOBER, A LOT OF THESE SHOWS
HAD RESTRICTIONS PLACED ON THEM,
NOT BY THE STATE, NOT BY THE
LOCAL CITY GOVERNMENT, NOT BY
THE LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT AND
MUNICIPALITIES, BUT BY THE
ACTUAL PROMOTERS/VENUE OWNERS.
>> Tucker: YES.
>> AND THERE WAS NOTHING THAT
JUSTIFIED THAT.
AND SO, I STARTED GETTING A TON
OF MESSAGES FROM FANS WHO WERE
BASICALLY NOT WARNED ABOUT THESE
MANDATES OR RESTRICTIONS AHEAD
OF TIME, SHOWED UP AT THE GATE,
AND WERE TURNED AWAY, AND WERE
NOT EVEN OFFERED REFUNDS, THEY
WERE OFFERED CREDITS TO AN
UPCOMING SHOW THAT HAD TO BE
USED WITHIN THE NEXT 12 MONTHS,
OR ELSE THEY WOULD LOSE THEIR
MONEY FOR TICKETS, AND IT WAS
JUST HEARTBREAKING TO ME.
THESE PEOPLE HAVE BEEN SHUT OUT
FROM GETTING A CHANCE TO GO SEE
CONCERTS FOR OVER A YEAR, AND
THEY ARE FINALLY GETTING A
CHANCE TO DO THAT AGAIN, AND NOW
THEY ARE BEING TURNED AWAY FOR
SOME UNEXPLAINED REASON, SO THIS
IS NOT ABOUT -- THIS IS NOT
ABOUT FOLLOWING THE SCIENCE OR
TRYING TO LOOK OUT FOR THE
SAFETY OF -- OF THE PEOPLE
THERE.
THIS IS ABOUT SOMETHING ELSE.
THIS IS TRYING TO DIVIDE PEOPLE.
THIS IS TRYING TO SHAME PEOPLE.
THIS IS TRYING TO BASICALLY
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST PEOPLE THAT
THEY DON'T FEEL ARE CLEAN ENOUGH
TO BE PART OF ENJOYING A CONCERT
LIKE THAT.
>> Tucker: MAN, THAT IS SO
NICELY PUT.
SO THE QUESTION IS, YOU ARE NOT
THE ONLY TOURING ARTIST WHO IS
EXPERIENCING THIS, BUT YOU ARE
ONE OF THE VERY FEW I'M AWARE OF
WHO HAS SAID ANYTHING ABOUT IT,
WHO SAID I'M NOT PUTTING UP WITH
THIS, I'M NOT GOING ALONG WITH
IT.
WHY DID YOU DECIDE NOT TO GO
ALONG WITH THIS?
BECAUSE YOU COULD HAVE JUST
IGNORED IT LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE
IS.
>> YOU KNOW, I COME FROM A
HARDWORKING, MIDDLE-CLASS
FAMILY.
AND I HAVE BEEN EXTREMELY -- I
CAME FROM NOTHING.
TO HAVE A WONDERFUL, WONDERFUL
CAREER THAT HAS LASTED FOR OVER
35 YEARS IN THIS BUSINESS, AND
TO SEE PEOPLE THAT I KNOW -- I
KNOW THESE PEOPLE, THESE ARE
HARDWORKING AMERICANS THAT JUST
WANT TO TAKE CARE OF THEIR
FAMILIES, PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE
FOR THEIR FAMILIES, PUT A ROOF
OVER THEIR HEAD, AND
OCCASIONALLY GO OUT AND
EXPERIENCE A CONCERT, YOU KNOW,
ENJOY THEMSELVES, FORGET ABOUT
ALL THEIR TROUBLES FOR A LITTLE
WHILE, AND TO BE ABLE TO ENJOY
ALL OF THOSE DIFFERENT THINGS,
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT I JUST, I
FELT LIKE I HAD TO STAND UP FOR
FREE AT HOME.
FREEDOM FOR ALL OF THOSE PEOPLE
TO BE ABLE TO GO OUT AND DO WHAT
THEY ENJOY DOING AND ENJOY A
CONCERT WITHOUT BEING HARASSED.
>> Tucker: MAN, AND YOU ARE
WILLING TO LOSE MON